It's great to welcome to the program today,
Jonathan Haber, who's the author of the new
book Critical Thinking from M.I.T.
Press.
Also, the guy behind logic check dot net,
a Web site that checks not just the facts,
but also the reasoning behind the news of
the day.
It's so great to have you on, Jonathan.
Great to be on, David.
So what what is the sort of origin of critical
thinking as a discipline?
Does it come from some of those philosophers
that many of us were introduced to in freshman
year of college?
Is it older than that?
Well, it definitely draws on those ancient
disciplines, certainly philosophy, optically
Western philosophy, the work of Aristotle,
but also more modern disciplines such as science,
particularly some of the early science.
That was a discourse between, you know, philosophers
and sort of Proteau scientists psychology
more recently and then most recently cognitive
science.
So actually, critical thinking itself, the
concept that there is a form of thinking unique
enough to be all called critical, distinct
from intelligence and wisdom is actually a
20th century concept.
The sum of the.
So we've seen, you know, what a media literacy
class can look like, teaching one to critically
analyze media messages, critical thinking
epistemology.
There's a lot of material on the Internet
is the reason that a lot of this material
is necessary, that these are not concepts
that we intuitively learn in the sense that
at some point, you know, a baby realizes that
the circle is not going to fit into the rectangular
pair, that, you know, the triangular peg or
whatever.
And it's an intuitive lesson.
Are the critical thinking skills that you
espouse and talk about in the book.
Are they not something humans intuitively
pick up?
Well, they're definitely not our intuitions
actually need to be disciplined, which is
why you need Strock to structure your thinking
in order to reason.
I think, you know, science is a good example
where people have not historically always
thought scientifically that was something
that was constructed.
And over centuries, really, the discipline
of thinking scientifically sort of developed
into a norm.
I think critical thinking is much more broad
than that.
It's something that you could apply not just
to science, but to every subject.
But it's not something that comes intuitively,
nor is it taught.
I mean, it used to be, you know, going back
to Roman times, logic, rhetoric, those were
the cornerstones of the educational curriculum,
right.
Through modernity.
But in modern times, we, of course, have many
more things to learn.
Modern science, history, cultures, language,
which is great.
But I think that math, that logic, rhetoric,
some of the critical thinking kind of core
foundational skills have been crowded out
in favor of new knowledge.
And I think that's one of the reasons we both
lack the intuition.
But we're not taught this in schools.
Are we currently sort of at a bad moment when
it comes to critical thinking skills in the
population at large?
I know we've been tracking an anti intellectual
movements certainly for a couple hundred years
with a pretty significant degree of specificity.
But is there some sort of like peak that we
are now experiencing or dearth maybe is the
right word?
You know, I think there's there's been some
golden age where everybody thought critically
and we've sort of fallen off since then.
I mean, there's always been a set of skills
that some people take on, some people don't.
Some people maybe more naturally inclined
towards thinking reasonably than others.
Or you have you know, what's very typical
is people will think critically about subjects
like their jobs.
Right.
They'll make decisions about, you know, your
carpenter, how to cut a piece of wood.
You're a computer programmer.
You could think very logically when you're
writing code.
But we will not apply it to things like political
decisions, whom to vote for or even sort of
interpersonal decisions.
So I think probably what makes this period
more nerve racking is that there are all kinds
of ways to support thinking poorly of critical
thinking is kind of thinking, well, there
are less productive ways of thinking.
You can believe whatever you already believe,
you know, KOC confirmation bias.
You can believe whatever you're told.
Right.
Just belief authority figures.
And I think now that we have a new media landscape,
particularly with social media, that allows
us to isolate ourselves into bubbles where
we don't really even have to listen to anybody
we disagree with.
I think a lot of the sort of toxic politics
and miscommunication we have is a result of,
you know, not so much that people aren't internalizing
the rules of critical thinking.
I think just as there there's there's more
sources of bad premises, I guess around is
the what is the mechanism that is most effective
at disarming one's critical thinking faculties?
I mean, you sort of alluded, in a way, personal
life's things and political things as opposed
to how it would work or may best cut a piece
of wood.
Is it sort of having a personal stake which
which blinds us maybe to applying the same
type of critical thinking we otherwise would?
Well, I think that that there's no critical
thinking skills.
You know, you you add your YouTube channel
where you cover many of the logical skills
that are vital to critical thinking.
That's what's covered a lot of critical thinking
courses you might take in college.
And there's a lot of material on the Internet,
on logic and fallacies and those sorts of
things.
So that's the sort of knowledge you need.
But then you need the skills to use that knowledge.
In other words, if we're talking about logic
for this example, you need to put those skills
to use look, put logical principles to use
a lot and lots of situations in your work,
in your school, in your life.
And you need to sort of favor thinking, reasonably,
thinking logically over other forms of reasoning,
such as just believing what you've already
believed.
But then there's a whole group of dispositions.
You know, you have to want to apply logic
to things that might make you uncomfortable,
like examining your own beliefs, for example.
And I think that without all three pieces,
without the knowledge, the skills and the
dispositions, you can't really be think of
yourself as a critical thinker.
So I'd say situations where people, you know,
are very skilled thinkers and certain parts
of their life, but turn off Ri's.
And when it comes up to other factors, that's
a form of sort of not thinking critically
in terms of not exercising proper critical
thinking dispositions.
Yeah.
So you can't teach some.
One, to want to examine their own beliefs.
Right.
I mean, if you could maybe encourage someone,
but it's not a teachable skill in the same
way that identifying fallacies would be.
I think it's a teachable accept that you can
learn about the sort of flaws in the human
makeup that are non cognitive, right?
Some of them are.
You know what?
We're where we can be led by emotions or instincts.
Right?
Those can overwhelm reason.
And also, you know, there's cognitive biases.
There's been a whole cottage industry of people
writing about a confirmation bias and anchoring
bias and all these various sort of, you know,
flaws in our reasoning.
So I think you can learn about the human mind's
makeup and understand that we are all susceptible
to flawed thinking and therefore we shouldn't
assume we're always right.
But I think in terms of of dispositions that
would fall in the category of kind of morals,
education, you know, that these are intellectual
virtues, right?
Open mindedness, faith and reason, intellectual
humility.
And I think you can learn those the same way
you learn other moral principles by example.
For example, if your household if these sort
of intellectual virtues are practiced, then
you'll tend to likely internalize them.
If you live in a household with dogmatic politics,
for example, or a place where fundamental
beliefs are never questioned, then you will
learn that.
You will learn that right.
You'll learn not to question beliefs.
So I think that they can be learned.
It's sort of like behaviors, you know, any
sort of ethical behavior.
You learn them over time when it comes to
to make this really concrete.
Given the subject matter of this program,
when it comes to political messages and material
that we get through corporate media and mass
media.
What would you say are the one or two sort
of lowest hanging fruit in terms of the principles
that, if more frequently applied, would lead
to far more informed people?
So like one that I might look at would be
just understanding correlation versus causation.
Right.
With corona virus, people who get really sick
tend to have lower vitamin D levels.
Is that a causation or is that a correlation
explained by something else?
The economy did well after something happened
with taxes.
Did it do well because of that?
Or are they both impact?
Right.
So that would be one that I would maybe consider.
But I'm curious what you would think about
as the most important, lowest hanging fruit
that would most help consumers of political
news.
Well, I think know correlation versus causation.
You know, much like the difference between
deductive and inductive reasoning and many
of the topics that go into being critical
think are those are all vital.
And I think the good news is one can learn
what they are and how to use them relatively
quickly.
I mean, I think your videos were three to
five minutes on each of these topics.
I did a program called Critical Voter that
sort of taught much of the same material that
would have surprised how easy it is to learn
those things.
So I think certainly, you know, the three
things I would recommend is, one, learn those
things because it doesn't take that much time.
But I think, you know, if you want the low
hanging fruit, the things to do would be,
one, to practice them, to use them as much
as possible.
Critical thinking is really a skill.
It's kind of like playing the piano or being
good at a sport.
Right.
The more you do it, the better you get.
There's one researcher who thinks critical
thinking is like, you know, a sport or an
instrument.
It takes 10000 hours to get really good at
it.
So I'd say because the knowledge and the techniques
are relatively easy to pick up, it's just
a question of how much you dedicate to practicing
them.
And then I guess the other piece, I'd say
at the lowest hanging fruit, even though might
be the most difficult, is shared ability,
you know, being charitable to opinions, especially
those you don't agree with.
I think the show you did last week, you referred
to Steel Manning, an argument which as opposed
to Straw manning an argument, naturally a
reflection of the principle of charity.
Right.
You should try to address the strongest version
of that opponent's argument rather than attacking
one flaw in it or coming up with a weak version
or a parody.
And that's relatively easy to do when it's
your own arguments you're looking to sort
of strengthen.
I think the hardest part is to treat opposing
arguments, treating arguments from people
who you fundamentally disagree with in a charitable
fashion.
But I think a lot of intellectual virtues
kind of derive from that spirit of charity
in the limited time we have.
Is there one specific example that you've
seen be one of the most difficult beliefs
or areas of subject matter for people to really
think critically about?
Well, the two big ones are obviously politics
and religion.
Right.
Because these both are fundamentally about
our identity.
And I think certainly as religion sort of
full of.
Fades as a foundation of our identity, our
sort of political identities take on many
qualities that were once sort of of of you'd
see and religious based conflicts, you know,
kind of the level of he didn't some.
So I would say, you know, the understanding
that any argument based on somebodies identity
is going to be have to treat, treated, be
treated very sensitively.
Right.
Because no, nobody ever changed their mind
about a belief fundamental their identity
because they lost in arguments.
Right.
Nobody changed their mind because they lost
argument on Twitter, for example.
But but but even sort of lost, you know, a
more civilized argument.
Right.
That might crack the ice.
That might sort of get you thinking, oh, maybe
there's some things I don't know or maybe
some of the things I believe I should question.
But changing your mind, changing beliefs about
something that's very, very personal to you,
there's something that leaves you very vulnerable.
So I think if if we want to change the minds
of others, which obviously, you know, your
program and and other media programs like
it are are looking to to you should sort of
do what you can to empathize with those you
disagree with.
Try to get into their heads, try to understand
what they're thinking and exercise.
I often challenge people on is, you know,
think about what arguments would get you to
change your mind about something that you
strongly believe in and that'll get you to
sort of understand the difficulty of such
a situation.
And once you could appreciate it, then I think
you might be in a better position to address
opponents or address people who you disagree
with in a more empathetic kind of thing, ultimately,
potentially more successful way.
The book is Critical Thinking.
We've been speaking with the author, Jonathan
Haber, whose work you can also find at logic
check dot net.
Jonathan, really appreciate your time and
it's been a pleasure having you.
Oh, thank you.
Thanks for all your work as well.